[Music]
we have the secretary responsible for
securing our border and our immigration
system
who doesn't recognize these charts as
being a problem i find that
extraordinary and
and extremely damning and i'm all for
legal immigration
but what we have done instead is just
open the doors we speak of lawful
pathways
and support of them and yet the prior
administration tore those down too
before we just continue the blame game
here how many children were processed
over a three-year period through that
program we would be pleased
to provide that data yeah i think it's
about 5 000 children
you're right exactly lawmakers as you
can see in the senate grilling dhs
secretary mayorkas over the ongoing
surge at our southern border
and now state leaders are joining the
cause as 20 republican governors have
sent a letter to the white house
urging them to take action on the border
immediately
one of the governors is on the border
sign that letter
texas governor greg abbott joins us
today from austin governor good morning
good morning steve how you doing i'm
doing okay you know mitt romney
had that graphic yesterday that showed
how
how to control the number of
apprehensions of people crossing into
the country
but according to secretary mayorkas
governor uh the border is
closed that is not how it looks
so i i don't know if uh secretary marcus
and the by administration
either don't have a clue what's going on
or they are purposefully misleading
their fellow americans because here are
the numbers
on the national level with regard to the
border patrol
they apprehended this last month in the
month of april
more than 170 000 people that is
a tenfold increase over the prior april
where they apprehended about 17 000
people
but also i can tell you what's going on
on the ground with regard to the state
of texas because
i have deployed the texas department of
public safety as well as the national
guard
and they have apprehended about 30 000
people who came across the border
they've arrested more than 900 people
coming across the border
but i got to tell you steve there's
something else a new dynamic
about what's going on on the border that
americans need to know about
and that is the increased apprehension
of fentanyl coming across the border
yes there may be people coming across
the border but there's dangerous drugs
coming across the border
for your audience who may not know two
milligrams
of fentanyl is a fetal um a fatal dose
and so know this we had over uh an 800
or almost 800 percent
increase april over april about the
amount of fentanyl
that has been apprehended by the texas
department of public safety
we have obtained enough fentanyl coming
across the border to kill
every single person in the state of new
york
and so this is a very deadly situation
happening on the border
the butt administration better make uh
wake up however steve this is the deal
because of what texas is doing on the
border is texas
that is securing the border we want
biden to pay for it
it seems fair absolutely fair because
you're doing the job that the federal
government
should be doing but they refuse to
governor also
you've been busy i know you just signed
the alcohol to go bill
and that is going to really help
struggling
restaurants because now in addition to
your takeout food
you'll be able to get a cocktail or a
beer or a wine or something like that as
well
well first for for the setting of where
we are in texas right now
all of our restaurants are a hundred
percent fully open and they have been
for a while uh this alcohol to go was
one of the measures that we put in place
during the course of the pandemic when
restaurants were not allowed to be open
100 percent
and so many restaurants owners have said
that this alcohol to go program that we
allow them to undertake during the
course of the pandemic
that is what kept them open and
operational
and had it not been for that they may
have had to shut down
but the point is that both restaurants
as well as
texans liked alcohol to go so much we
decided to make it
permanent law well there you go and now
it is all right governor thank you very
much for joining us from
austin have a great weekend y'all too
thanks
you bet